You disrupted the
leadership campaign.
You're disrupting
the mayoral campaign.
You should be the
next prime minister.
You're very sweet.
They've left the centre.
The parties have been captured.
They're not coming back.
How can two parties
possibly do justice
to what modern Britain is?
That sort of sense of
people wanting a disruption
is palpable, I think.
I've seen outsiders
go up in flames
because they haven't
had a clue how
the political system and
politics actually work.
As an entrepreneur,
when I started out
I got nothing but nice
things happen to me.
Politics is
completely different.
I can't say anything
nice about it.
It is literally a viper's nest.
Political disruptors
are tempting voters
away from the UK's
two big main parties.
Competition is fierce with
would-be radical options
on the nationalist right and
even on the centre ground.
Britain's politics
is being shaken up.
And the result of
December's general election
has never been so uncertain.
The 2016 Brexit vote exploded
the usual left-right alignment.
There are now at least four
parties battling it out.
One of the insurgents,
the Brexit party,
is led by Nigel Farage, whose
lifelong dream for the UK
to quit the EU may be
about to come true.
There will be no Brexit
without the Brexit party.
Of that, I'm certain.
Brexit's thrown it all up
in the air because that
went beyond left and right.
And the political
parties haven't
known how to react to a
major political decision that
didn't fall under party lines.
The other challengers
want to stop Brexit.
But they also hope to
capitalise on the upheaval.
Some form of tumult was probably
inevitable in British politics
because whenever you go
through big societal change,
you see tumult.
Professor Jane Green, of
the British Election Study,
maps and measures the UK's
changing voting patterns.
We went to Oxford asked how
Britain went from this to this?
From the 1960s through to
today we see more people
switching their vote between
general elections over time.
So a much more fluid
volatile picture.
So does this volatility
mean that it's
kind of fertile territory?
That there are
opportunities there
for the political disruptors?
You've got a very
available electorate.
You've got opportunities
for the political parties.
What you've also got is
loads of uncertainty.
You can see there's a
disruption going on,
and we don't know where
it's going to land.
Claire Fox, a Libertarian from
the left was elected as an MEP
for the Brexit party earlier
this year as voters deserted
both Labour and the Tories.
Of course, change is always
unpredictable, isn't it?
Makes it scary.
So is democracy.
But to argue against
disruption on the basis
of 'things worked' completely
misunderstands that for many
people, they didn't.
So we've talked a bit about
things being more up for grabs.
Yeah.
I'm going to try and
ask you to explain
where the voters might be.
So you think about one dimension
of politics from left to right.
And within that
kind of left-right,
bread and butter economic kind
of way of seeing the world,
lots of people have
left of centre views.
Lots people have
right of centre views,
but the majority of people
would be in the middle.
And therefore, it makes politics
very much about that kind
of centre ground, about
competing for the majority
of voters.
Britain has always been about
understatement, compromise,
pragmatism.
And I think that's
where the energy is.
I think it resonates deeply.
Rory Stewart is
leaving parliament.
He's left the
Conservative party.
He wants to reinvent
moderate politics
by standing as an independent
candidate for London mayor.
I think actually
the UK's traditions
are much more consensual,
much more designed
for centre-ground politics than
almost anywhere in the world.
That dimension is still very
important to voter choice now.
But of course, we've all started
seeing the world predominately
through the lens of Brexit.
And Brexit isn't about bread
and butter left-right issues
on the whole, it's about
this different dimension
that cross cuts the
left-right dimension.
It's divided the party, and
it's divided the voters.
A lot of people who thought
of themselves at centre ground
in the old politics, in the new
politics are far from centre
ground.
Chuka Umunna walked out of
Labour earlier this year,
attempted to start a new
anti-Brexit centre party,
Change UK, but is now trying
to redefine opposition politics
from within the pro-European
Liberal Democrats.
Those guys are no
longer centre ground.
They are firmly on the liberal,
internationalist, open,
anti-authoritarian side
of the new dichotomy.
So when people say to me I want
a return to good centre ground
policies, I'm kind of like, but
you're no longer centre ground.
You are actually
firmly in one camp.
Political scientists
like you are
used to thinking about
voters in this rather more
complicated way.
In the past, we think
about it in terms
of people that had more socially
conservative views and more
socially liberal views.
But also we're now
thinking much more
about people that have
anti-immigration views and also
pro-immigration views
and also anti-European or
Brexit-supporting, Leave-voting
views or more pro-European,
Remain-supporting views.
And so we have the
impression that politics
has become much more polarised.
Both the Brexit party
and the radical Remainers
are betting that politics
is now about values.
There's different fault
lines, aren't there?
So what's happened is rather
than saying the big decision
in British politics today
is whether we nationalise
the railways it's
actually our attitude
to popular sovereignty.
So you asked me the
question, where is the space?
Yeah, where's the opportunity?
So on the one hand, we talked
about kind of important.
So if this issue
becomes less important,
then we might worry
about left-right again.
But what if this
issue, dimension,
doesn't become less important?
But at the current
time, it feels
and looks in terms
of the evidence
that people are pretty divided.
If you look at some
of the people who've
been running our country,
some of the decisions we've
made in the last
decade or so, you
go, how is such a brilliant
country in this mess?
Simon Franks, once a
committed Labour party backer,
is dismayed by
this polarisation.
He's been spending time
and money trying to use his
start-up skills to shake
up centre ground politics.
The mission was to
scope out initially,
is it possible to create a
new political party that could
win in one electoral cycle?
Can you, in politics, do
something that kind of maps
entrepreneurialism
onto party politics?
Yes, you can but,
not in the centre.
If you're on the wings
of British politics,
or in fact, any politics,
and you have a cause,
you can mobilise people
incredibly quickly
to bring about a
change because people
are so desperate for
that change or believe
so strongly in that cause.
In the centre it's much harder
to do because, by definition,
you should be more
balanced, more reasonable.
You understand that
no one issue is
going to make our country
completely better or completely
worse.
Josef Lentsch believes in
the power of the middle.
This Austrian academic helped
start a successful new party
and has written a book
on how to make it work.
It's bloody hard.
It's bloody hard
for politicians.
These days, the political
itch to be scratched
is that many people feel
not represented anymore.
And too many of them
then decide to vote
for populists and nationalists.
But I think many of
them would actually
like to have a choice
to vote for something
different and constructive.
The primary reason why Change
UK didn't succeed in the way
that we would have liked
it to is, as you said,
I'm not sure people were looking
for disruption in as much
as they were looking
for their politics
to be properly represented.
But they weren't necessarily
precious about the vehicle
through which you do that.
And to try and
create something new
in a non-presidential system
is nigh on impossible.
In a sense you, can't just
compete on one dimension.
People want to know
where you stand.
So if you're competing
on this dimension,
but you're divided
on this dimension
because you've got
parties from the left,
parties from the right,
then essentially, OK fine.
So you've got this
bit sorted out.
But are you over
here on the left?
Or are you here on
the right in terms of
where your voters
are likely to be?
I think the most important
thing is if you want to build
a centrist alternative, that
you're actually early on are
starting to talk to the voters
and start to interlink what I
call, 'islands of discontent.'
Most political
start-ups will fail.
I think that's not a problem.
I think actually many, many
need to try for some of them
to succeed.
Once you've broken the
habits of a lifetime -
at the European election,
obviously everything got thrown
in the air - then
you're not quite that,
we always vote
Labour in our family.
We always vote
Tory in our family.
Anything can happen.
It's like when MPs rebel
against a whip, right?
Once they get the taste for
it, it becomes possible again.
Even those people who are
saying: let's get Brexit done,
their argument is,
let's get Brexit done
so we can go back to normal.
And I think they underestimate
the appetite for a much more
fundamental shift.
Nothing's ever going
to go back, ever.
The problem is that the
government of the centre has
always seemed terribly sort
of bureaucratic and inert.
It doesn't really
seem to listen.
It doesn't seem to
engage, which gives people
the idea that maybe
there's a silver bullet,
maybe there's some
fantastic thing.
And it's some character.
An ideology.
Yeah, an ideology.
Or a person.
Like a hand grenade you
can chuck at the system,
and the whole thing's
going to blow up.
And suddenly, it's all
going to be much better.
So there's no messiah coming.
No, there can't be a messiah.
I mean, I think I'm also...
Not you.
No, definitely not me.
We've had conspicuous
examples of success
on both the left and the right.
I'm thinking of Nigel
Farage on one side,
probably Labour's
Momentum on the other.
But there's this whole space
in the centre with lots
of plotting, lots of activity.
But it's really hard to
make something happen.
It's a much easier message.
So Nigel Farage, who I think
is a brilliant communicator
and I don't have this
disregard for him
as so many people seem to have.
I think he speaks
for a large community
of our country about issues
that no one else will talk to.
I think the same on the left.
Jeremy Corbyn gets on
the stage and says,
capitalists are bad people.
The reason why your life
isn't as good as you'd like it
is because of that
bunch over there.
And some people, they go,
the messiah's arrived.
No one's got a
monopoly on grievance.
In the wake of the crash,
in the wake of austerity,
in the wake of
globalisation, taking away
the securities that
people took for granted,
the question is, what
you do about that?
We've completely failed to
produce a product that's
really exciting.
I mean, none of these
third-party centre party
leaders have actually worked out
how to produce something that
really makes the public think,
woo, well, OK, all right,
actually, I'm not going to vote
the way that my parents voted.
This election is not the end.
And I think the most
important thing to note
is this election's been called
in very peculiar circumstances.
But I personally think that
the genie's out the bottle.
And that what we are likely
to see in the next five years
is a very disruptive
political scene.
In the first winter
election for decades,
established parties are being
buffeted from all sides.
There are wide open spaces
in the political landscape
and enormous potential
for storms to come.
Jane, if you had
to put money on it,
would you bet on political
insurgents, either a smaller
party or a new party
trying to replace or split
one of the two main parties?
If the two mainstream parties
adapt their positions,
working out kind
of where can they
attract the majority of voters,
then it's very difficult,
it's still very difficult for
minor parties to break through.
In normal times, I
would say that it's
impossible to actually get a
new party in the UK parliament.
But we are not in normal times.
We're past normal times.
And I think, therefore,
don't give up hope.
That there might be
something on the way.
We can probably do better
if we think about it,
redesign our political system,
reinvigorate our parties,
maybe create some
new ones, maybe look
at our voting system, look
the way we select MPs,
look at the way treat MPs
Anyone who believes that
everything goes back to normal
is kidding themselves.